qu'est-ce que kepler nous enseigne
nourrisent
nous ne devons pas penser à nous
nous ne devons pas écouté nos émotions
nous agissons pour le bien de tous
on l'appelait la terre nourricière
nous avons pillé toutes ses ressources
la recherche sur les techniques de
procréation a échoué pour les hommes
comme pour les femmes ils veulent une
preuve qu'on peut progresser
ces survivants
frau
sans émetteur radio
c'est un comble non
magna
pourquoi est ce que tu me suis
vous aider
on attendait depuis si longtemps je suis
tellement content de te voir louise
il est impératif qu'on procède au
rapatriement des exilés
est-ce qu'ils rient
[Musique]
l'humanité n'a pas besoin de nous pour
survivre
tous tu es toujours dans notre camp
blake
on
pour
aucun n'aurait dû revenir
[Musique]